holy smokes the trailers they just don't
stop this is Guillermo del Toro's new
movie called Pacific Rim and I was an
opposite forum like a war movie kind of
but not really
more or less chaos is spreading around
but then I remembered I was like ah
there's that viral video where the big
monster starts chomping on things and
that's pretty much the premise of the
movie there was a big crack in the
ground and monsters have come out of it
now they're just gonna wipe us all out
something out there had discovered us
but mankind was like ah we got you
covered because we watched Power Rangers
growing up so yeah we had a contingency
for this [ __ ] so now we have big robots
that people get into and control and
kick the [ __ ] out of the monsters
and at first I was like that sounds
remarkably cheesy but this might just be
awesome and we got interest Elba in
command yet there's no way we're gonna
lose this war we win we know that right
now at the edge of our hope at the end
of our time we've chosen to believe in
each other
I'm not even going to say this movies
like transformers because that's
completely cutting it short it's not
really like transformers this movie
alright here's what it's like Pacific
Rim is like Power Rangers and Real Steel
had a kid and real still got pregnant
with the love child Ninh Real Steel
cheated on Power Rangers with Godzilla
and then got pregnant with Godzilla's
love child also and inside the fetuses
joined to make some cinematic super baby
called Pacific Rim that is this movie
operations [ __ ] dangerous yeah yeah but
wait wait a minute what what say
something again robot voice pilots ready
to connect let's go fishing
- and aged in your little brain is that
GLaDOS from Portal if it's not GLaDOS
from Portal it's GLaDOS from Portal
because no one really knows how to
pronounce your name but it's her
thank you our let's get started
that is the robot that messed with my
mind for two games right backtracking a
little bit any human beings who were
controlling big mechs to stomp on
Godzilla monsters get out of the mechs
now she's going to kill you we're gonna
lose she's gonna feed you promises of
cake the cake is [ __ ] we're dead
meat GLaDOS wins that is totally her
from Portal and I personally Pilar
bitching about how can you [ __ ] about
that dude really I gotta think someone
on the production team of Pacific Rim
was like dude alright I'm gonna slip in
Gladys's voice from Portal and know it
like it by the time anyone notice this
is gonna be too late good job whoever
did that you are a patriot
in reality though monster movies are
really tough to do is it you can make
her but it's usually great be [ __ ]
where it costs five bucks to mega people
are like this is gonna bomb in the box
out it's not gonna do well think I del
Toro behind it though that makes people
go wait a minute you mean they're really
trying this time I get there's been
Cloverfield some monster movies did work
and people did like them but monster war
movies where you fight them with robots
how did you even pitch that to a studio
today we are canceling the apocalypse
you
so yeah and a bizarre and strange turn
of events I'm looking forward to this
movie if you give me Godzilla with
robots with a credible director I'm
probably gonna be like all right yeah
let's do that
at least I have to see the Pacific Rim
have you seen the trailer what do you
think about this movie comment below let
me know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more